[Music]
i believe we have a choice in this world
about how to tell sad stories on the one
hand
you can sugarcoat it when nothing is too
messed up that can't be fixed with a
peter gabriel song
i like that version as much as the next
girl does
it's just not the truth this is the
truth
doctors appointments reality shows worst
of all
support groups christ is
all right hazel how are you doing
you mean besides the cancer all right i
guess
why don't i play another song
you need to be a teenager if you want me
to be a teenager you don't send me to
support
group you gotta give me a fake id so
that i can go to clubs and take pot
uh you don't take pot that is the kind
of thing i would know with a fake id
hey make some friends sorry
not bad i'm augustus waters i've been in
remission for about a year and a half
maybe you'd like to share some of your
fears with the group
oblivion what's your name hazel
why are you staring at me because you're
beautiful
really you just ruined this whole thing
the whole thing yes this whole thing
oh man you're doing really well too i
never lit one
huh it's a metaphor see you put the
thing that does the killing right
between your teeth
but you never give up the power to kill
you a metaphor
so what's your story who's diagnosed in
a certain way no no
not your cancer story your real story
your hobbies your passions your weird
fetishes
i am quite unextraordinary i reject that
at the hand
you know gus talks about you all the
time we're just friends
you're trying to keep your distance from
me and no weight lessens my affection
for you
gus i'm a grenade one day i'm gonna blow
up
and i'm gonna obliterate everything in
my wake and i don't want to hurt you
you don't get to choose if you get hurt
in this world but you do have a say in
who hurts you
i am in love with you hazel grace and i
know that love is just a shout into the
void and that oblivion is inevitable
and i am in love with you all your
efforts to keep me from you're going to
[Music]
fail
[Music]
are you angry so angry you need to break
something
i fell in love with him the way you fall
asleep
slowly and then all at once it's a good
life hazel grace
okay okay
[Music]
maybe it's time to let the old ways down
maybe it's time to live
[Applause]
[Music]
you know man in the old days
i always knew like you were gonna do
something
that you'd be all right it's the first
time i'm worried about you
[Music]
can i ask you a personal question okay
tell me something girl
do you write songs or anything i don't
sing my own songs
why i just don't feel comfortable
well when you feel comfortable almost
every single person has told me they
liked the way i sounded but that they
didn't like the way i look
i think you're beautiful
hey what i just want to take another
look at you
in all the good times i find myself
along him
here's what we're gonna do you come sing
that song what i love no i can't do that
here we go look at me
all you gotta do is
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this was fun wait we haven't even had
sex again yet
i'm just not that kind of girl i only
have sex once on the first date
i'm just gonna call an uber
[Music]
your travel will be right as soon as he
puts on his pants
what you learn by oh crust i have to
tell you something bye
i've been dating this girl she's white a
white girl
hey you can't look like you and male
white girl it's okay we hate terrace
i wonder who that could be i'm guessing
it's a young single pakistani woman
this is zubaida for your files your
x-files that's your favorite show huh
the truth is out there
are you judging pakistan's next top
model you know how we have arranged
marriage in my culture
oh my god i'm so stupid can you imagine
a world in which we end up together
i don't know i'm looking for emily
gardner she was checked
in tonight there's an infection we put
her in a medically induced coma
coma you should call her family thank
you come on
we're gonna handle things from here i
think i'm just gonna wait anyway
i broke up i'm not sure why you're here
i'm just gonna stay for a second
it's the seat
[Music]
is that lady still looking at me
so uh 911. i've always wanted to have a
conversation with
people you've never talked to people
about 911.
i'm still doing anything you gotta call
the games now i give a play you can't
rhyme it you try to find a word and
nobody can rhyme
okay
yeah see you would win yeah
[Music]
i think i screwed up with your daughter
yeah
let me give you some advice come on love
isn't easy
that's why they call it love
i don't really get that i thought i
could just start saying something and
something small would come out
25 years of marriage you have nothing to
say
i'll just say it i slept with someone if
you keep talking i'm gonna get out of
the car think the fact that i did it it
just shows how broken we are
how much how much we really oh my god
you're getting a divorce yeah amy heard
you crying in the bathroom
we all thought it was cancer oh thank
god man
yeah just my relationship
[Music]
hi can i buy you a drink uh-huh let's
get out of here wanna get out of here
what are you doing later i don't know i
do there's lots of beautiful women in
this bar but i can't take my eyes off of
you it's time to go home
oh it's forward of you but okay should i
pull the car around you've been drinking
i'll drive
hey ladies man guy any tips of the trade
your wife cheated on you because you
lost sight of who you are as a man
let's take that straw to your mouth it
looks like you're sucking on it
okay you're sitting there with a
supercuts haircut
and you're wearing a 44mm you should be
wearing 42 regular credit card
where are your wallets did you sleep
with him
geez god yeah probably you would
you got to take control of your manhood
pal can you put on some clothes please
i'm sorry is this bothering you
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
what do you want to do with me i want to
show you after my ex-wife make her
really jealous
i met a girl and she is a game changer
she's your soul mate right go get her
back wow how old are you
i'm in love with her and i don't know
what to do about it
[Music]
i don't know when you and i stopped
being us you know when i told you that i
had to work late i really went to see
the new twilight movie by myself
[Music]
why can we take off your shirt seriously
it's like you're photoshopped
[Music]
thank you so much
i can show you around that'd be great
thank you
[Music]
so what do you do around here read books
transcribe music
swim at the river go out at night that
sounds fun all right
later
[Music]
just watch this is how we'll say goodbye
to us when the time comes
later meanwhile we'll have to put up
with him for six long weeks
muscles are firm not a straight body in
these statues they're all curved
sometimes impossibly curved and so
nonchalant hence their ageless
ambiguity as if they're daring you to
desire them
all to see without my eyes
[Music]
is there anything you don't know
boundless by the time i cry you only
knew how little i know about the things
that matter
what things that matter
[Music]
you know what things
[Music]
just pretend you never
[Music]
ways of did our weakest spartans
[Music]
call me by your name and i'll call you
by mine
[Music]
what am i in for here
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
we come from such different worlds
[Music]
[Music]
i just came to drop this off would you
get that
from your car i haven't been able to
read these for years
you want me to read them to you
april 10th and 19th my dearest truth
i'll remember that dress you wore even
when i forgotten my own name
i wish i could tell you little oldie
happily ever after
not everybody gets that
you did
[Music]
wasn't that simple
[Music]
luke you need to stop or next time
you're more likely going to pick him up
at the morgue this is my life
it's all i know i can't be with someone
if every time they walk out the door i
don't know if i'm going to see them
again
promise me to come back i promise
i just don't want to make this work i
can't do this anymore
love requires sacrifice
but it's worth it
[Laughter]
life's all about moments of impact and
how they change our lives
forever but what if one day you could no
longer
remember any of them kate you're in the
hospital you were in a car accident
any pain my head hurts doctor
[Applause]
she doesn't remember me her memory is
going to improve with time
we miss you coming home to life i don't
know that's a lot to take in
we'll figure this out together in the
morning
what please knock this habit i'm sorry
[Music]
the last memory that i have is being
engaged to jeremy
ex-fiance jeremy oh no no in her mind
it's current
fiance jeremy i need to make my wife
fall in love with me again
i want to ask you out on a date like two
people that are just meeting for the
first time
a date huh and i just have to be back by
10 in the morning
oh my god what first date you're already
inviting yourself to stay the night what
i don't know i'm just a little
scandalized as well
you can't remember how we fell in love
you get to experience it all over again
this is the exact parking spot where we
first met
back and forth
[Music]
she doesn't remember you leo you like
this right
a little bit i'm trying to save what we
have
i hope one day i can love the way that
you love me
you figured it out once you'll do it
again
no matter what challenges might carry us
apart we will always find a way back to
each other
[Music]
it was a magical summer noah was a
country boy
ali was from the city they met the night
of the carnival
they had nothing in common but after
seeing ali that night
something inside noah snapped
[Music]
me no no damn my head
okay fine i'll go out with you don't do
me any favors no i want to
say it again
[Music]
they fell in love didn't they yes they
did you want to dance with me
sure this is a good story i think i've
heard it before
it's like a dream so what do you do noah
i work at the lumber yard how much did
you make at your job 40 cents an hour
it has got to stop noah he's a nice boy
but he is not for you
i see how it's gonna work you want not
to see him anymore and that's final
from the best-selling novel by nicholas
sparks
ole miss how's about that date comes a
story
it's normal not to forget your first
love but i want you for myself
marry me about what we long for
i saw your picture in the paper and i
just wanted to see if you were okay
what we settled for i have a fiance
waiting for me
what happened who did you choose and who
we're meant for why didn't you write me
i waited for you for
seven years i wrote you every day for a
year
new line cinema presents ryan gosling
rachel mcadams james garner jenna
rowlands
james marsden with sam shepard and joan
allen
in a nick cassavetes film i read to her
and she remembers
the notebook
when i was a kid this is my favorite
place in the whole world i think this
would still be my
favorite spot that's because you haven't
been anywhere oh so where's better than
this then
paris
[Music]
if i shut my eyes now i know exactly how
it feels to be in that little square
so let's go we could get on the eurostar
right now
you don't get it clark i want to be in
paris as me
the old me there she
goes in front of me
[Music]
use the time he's got left show him how
good his life can be
we've barely left the house in two years
we have tried yes but we haven't
succeeded
will needs to be allowed to feel like a
man can i take you somewhere
you are so going on a date with will
trainer it's too baby get the red dress
out we'll make
memory out of it loose the scarf if
you're gonna wear a dress like that
clark
you have to wear it with confidence only
you will trainer will tell a woman how
to wear a bloody dress
you know you never would have let those
breaths so near to me if i was in the
wheelchair
yeah well you never would have been
looking at these breasts if you hadn't
been in a wheelchair
what of course i would no you wouldn't
you wouldn't you would have been too
busy looking at the leggy blondes the
ones you can smell an expensive gown at
40 bases and anyway
i would have been over there serving the
drinks one of the invisibles
am i right yes but in your defense
i was an artist
[Music]
you know something clark you are pretty
much the only thing that makes me want
to get up in the morning
and let's go somewhere anywhere in the
world see you and me
what do you say
say yes well
[Music]
you can you can do anything
[Music]
i don't want you to miss all the things
that someone else could give you
i have become a whole new person because
of you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
repository
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
her coming out of the darkness like a
ghost ship still gets me every time
take a look at this drawing that we
found just today a piece of paper that's
been underwater for 85 years
i'll be damned all right you have my
attention can you tell us who the woman
in the picture is
oh yes the woman in the picture is me
louis xvi wore a stone called the blue
diamond of the crown
and today it would be worth more than
the hope diamond if your grandmother's
who she says she is
she was wearing the diamond the night
the ship sank i really think she was
there
oh yeah i'm a believer
are you ready to go back to titanic
string i could the book is on the
grandest ship in history and you act as
if you're going to your execution
[Music]
i'll forget a boy you'll never get next
to the likes of her
[Music]
i know you've been melancholy i don't
pretend to know why
don't come any closer i'll let go no you
won't
why can't i be like you jack just head
out for the horizon whenever i feel like
it
i've got 10 bucks in my pocket nothing
to offer you and i know how the world
works
i'm flying
what made you think you could put your
hands on my fiance
they've got you trapped rose and if you
don't break free you're gonna die
it's a ship there's only so many places
she can be find her
icebergs
i have been robbed is this it don't you
believe it rose
don't you understand the water is
freezing and there aren't enough burps
half the people on the ship are going to
die not the better half what do we do
mommy when i finish putting first class
people on the bus it'll be starting with
us
all the way why are the boats half full
for god's sake there's nothing down here
[Music]
i hope you enjoy your time together
[Music]
i got to stay on the ship as long as
possible
this is where we
oh first gosh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you